un apretón de manos muy esperado el
secretario de estado estadounidense
Anthony blinken concluyó su viaje a
China el primero de un jefe de la
diplomacia de Washington en cinco años
en Beijing blinken se reunió con el
mandatario chino un acercamiento
diplomático de 35 minutos destinado a
desenredar las relaciones entre ambas
potencias económicas mientras trabajamos
en nuestras diferencias Estados Unidos
está preparado para cooperar con china
en áreas en las que tenemos intereses
mutuos incluido el clima la estabilidad
macroeconómica la salud pública la
seguridad alimentaria y la lucha contra
las drogas ambos coincidimos en la
necesidad de estabilizar nuestra región
la visita de dos días estaba programada
para febrero pero fue suspendida debido
a la polémica por el globo espía Chino
derribado Sobre suelo estadounidense y
sucede en un momento de grandes
tensiones por sus posiciones entre otros
temas en cuanto a Taiwán Washington se
mostró enfático en que su visión sobre
la política de Beijing de una sola china
no ha cambiado pero aseguró que ambas
partes abogan ahora por el
apaciguamiento la reunión con el
presidente tampoco estaba programada lo
que los analistas apuntan a un gesto más
próximo al deshielo
las dos partes también han logrado
avances y han llegado a un acuerdo sobre
algunos temas específicos esto es muy
bueno las interacciones entre Estados
Unidos deben basarse siempre en el
respeto mutuo y la sinceridad Espero que
a través de esta visita señor secretario
haga más contribuciones positivas a la
estabilización de las relaciones entre
China y Estados Unidos
el encuentro podría abrir la puerta a un
proceso para un mayor compromiso
diplomático entre Beijing y Washington
Hace unos días el mismo presidente Joe
biden insinuó una posible reunión con su
homólogo chino